do you all realize that it was three
years ago almost to the date that red
table talks started
and now it has become like a part of the
culture of the vernacular it's in
songs you hear it everywhere did you
have these kind of dreams or
has it just gone blown past your wildest
dreams
isaac passed yeah 100 percent we had no
idea it was going to be none yeah it was
a passion project
that started on mother's day okay and
then
ellen came and she was like what are you
guys gonna do with this three
generational
situation and i was like well you know
we've been approached a couple times but
willow was young and
she was like i think we should do
something so i went to willow and i went
to gammy because willa was older because
when we first did it well how old were
you 11.
yeah 11 12. so six years later
because we started when you were like
17. we started again when she was like
17 18 years old that's crazy
yeah what has been the moment for y'all
what has been your favorite moment
of of this journey there has been so
much uncovering
on this journey that we've been on with
red table talk and
i feel like my the part about the whole
process that i cherish the most
is just getting to know the women in my
life
in a more just a deeper way and getting
to
really know them as not just my
grandmother and not just my mother but
as
the individual women that they are
that's kind of how it started her
asking mom you know i want to know you
and not just you as my mother i was like
right
[Laughter]
you know what i mean who are you who
were you i think you said something like
who were you before you were my mother i
was like
that's a conversation but there's been
so much healing
you know just for us bonding and healing
as a family
and it's been so nice to just be
um i don't know just more authentic
exactly yeah just as a family i really
felt like
you needed an opportunity to tell your
story at least
and then people can decide whatever yeah
they want to believe whatever they want
to believe
right people have found this comfort
zone though with y'all
where they are coming to you and they
feel safe
at the table and they talk to you and
that's a rare thing
in this business you know that's
something you have to build up so how
has that been
wow i think it's been beautiful yeah
and i think jada really sets the tone
for that 100
yeah i tend to be and i'm working on it
but i tend to be um a little judgmental
and
so no she's a boomer that's what we love
though because gary
is that's why it's like the voice of the
audience yeah let me tell you it's team
gaming all day exactly
like and so people like you know games
gonna come to the table reason
he's coming with all that fluff love
it's been a real learning experience and
an
opportunity for me to just just
try to open my mind up and just be a
little bit more
uh easy with with things
and with change you know what i mean you
can't you can't just stay stuck in this
world but this has been different for
you because you are the voice of the
audience
and you have also turned out to be kind
of the breakout star
and the sexism and let's not forget the
sex symbol of it all
right let's be real about it when did
that happen when did it happen
you got a grown man telling you that
that's what's happening listen
already you were getting a lot of love
and then you posted the bathing suit
pictures yeah
willow took the picture and jada posted
it
kev is like how has that been for you
i mean it's been great it's been great i
mean it's all good fun i don't i don't
take myself too seriously come on now
i'm 67. i know
i i've tried you know okay that's the
craziest thing
craziest thing ever ever a lot of dudes
slipping in your dms now right like
y'all really trying to slip up in there
and hit you up and
i don't even know if you know how to get
it get anything yes
you're gonna have to teach her how to
get in those dm's maybe i don't want to
from the sounds of it
yeah so what are y'all doing this year
for mother's day
what because i know you do it big what
will you do this year for mother's day
what are we doing i think we're just
going to have a real chill barbecue
oh that would be nice and celebrate
together yeah
and just chill and eat and by the way
isn't it kind of cool when your children
follow in your footsteps a little bit
and pay tribute to that's kind of cool
isn't it
it's i told all the kids i say you will
do
bigger and greater things than your
parents right
not in the same way necessarily but like
when i look
at willow jaden and trey
trey in a much different way willow and
jaden have followed our footsteps as far
as
you know being in the business and what
have you
but willow her musicianship
far exceeds i believe
both her parents far far
far far far exceeds you know what i mean
and so when i look at her as a musician
as an artist i'm so proud of her
you've been doing it mama you've been
doing it
and this new record is an alt-rec it's
an alt-rock record
yeah right so it's a little bit
following your mama's footsteps
i mean i wouldn't i it's a little bit i
mean
punk and heavy metal are very very
different
yeah um but they are definitely in the
rock world they're they're they're
i would say they're cousins yeah i
wouldn't say siblings because that's a
little too close
right but cousins when beyonce said my
name is
have you all had a favorite guest
i've had several yeah i wanna
i wanna say i don't think it's come out
yet
but um the professor that we just had
michael dyson yeah michael dyson yeah oh
talking with him was spectacular
yeah i i just loved his mind and his
intelligence and how he
just thought about how he thinks about
the world it's just it's so amazing
willow's such an academic so
yeah she actually shouldn't have gone to
college but i might still
yeah don't don't so when michael came
she felt like she was
in one of his classes i'm at a lecture
right now
you know what i think there's been so
many but what
really comes to my mind was just such an
honor was dr
angela davis um yeah that was that was a
powerful moment for me
yeah yeah that was probably that was a
powerful moment for all of us 100
yeah but there have been so many there's
been so many yeah i can't even say that
there's
one for me no not one like i always love
when um people can come and and
and share their truth and feel so well
taken care of
yeah you know we've had so many that
have
come and needed to share their stories
um and felt like red table was the only
place and then actually shared their
story and we would get an email from
them or
email from their team and it makes me
feel so good when people feel like when
they call and they go
thank you you know this was a streaming
platform and at first
people were like oh a streaming plan
how's that going to work how's it going
how is it going to be were there where
those moments figuring it out
because now people know when where
how it's like you adapted almost a
generation
to this kind of programming would what
did that mean and how did you how did
you work that out
it was really important to me when we
were shopping and of course we had
networks that wanted it and what have
you but
i knew that facebook watch was going to
give us the opportunity to make the most
authentic
show yeah and i also knew that they were
going to
follow our lead and that's what i felt
was really important
that they that team over there really
believed in the vision
and they believed in our leadership in
regards to how we wanted to make this
show
and i also wanted a community
you know i wanted a community so that
when the conversation was
over when we were done that there were
people that could still gather
yes talk and commune about whatever
together together so there's been like
different red table talk
communities all over facebook that have
popped up
you know what i mean and so that's also
been a really deep
blessing and treasure you know it's an
interesting thing you mentioned about
a place where it's not going to be
sensationalized and people can feel free
to
speak their mind and everything and
that's a problem that happens is that
everything gets
sensationalized and and you guys have
figured out the way
to amp it down i mean yeah i do
appreciate how you got after olivia j
i do appreciate that oh my goodness so
let me ask you if you have a clear
understanding of what
white privilege really is now but what
is th
what is that like when people come in
here and they are
they're nervous they're scared they're
worried all of them are yeah
everybody is it is so interesting
because i always try to
like remind them that it's like this is
not a place where we just sit and judge
you like this is a place where we openly
converse and we're not trying to attack
anybody even me
i'm not trying to attack anybody
it's also important that we see a black
family having these conversations
generational that everyone can come
together and sit down and see that
how important have you seen a change
because i know for black folks it's like
okay we can talk we can all sit down and
talk about this
right and fix it right yeah for me like
when i'm out in the street
it's all people yeah exactly you know
it's like
of course for the black community
you know what i mean because we're black
so of course the black community
they like right you know what i mean
they're like thank you for showing up
for
you know for us but i think people in
general like i have
all kinds of people from all walks of
life
i'm telling you i mean people i would
never even
think are watching red table talk from
60 year old white men
to like you know 16 year old
boys you know what i mean it's just so
beautiful
that we've been able to connect with
such a variety you know so many groups
of
of people from different generations and
from different
countries and you know from different
economic backgrounds
you know on a common ground all on a
common ground of just
trying to figure out how to live a happy
authentic
life willow how about you what have you
learned about these two or
what have they taught you through this
experience i
i think that just
even not in the immediate
like show circumstances but in hearing
their stories
and in hearing what they've been through
together in their past
um seeing how
intense the evolution has been from
where you guys
started at and how your relationship
started
yeah um and how much your relationship
has grown
because you individually have grown is
it crazy listening to your child
say these kind of thing like it's
amazing to listen to you say these
really adult thoughts and processes that
we all need to kind of take in
well see this is the thing willow's been
talking like that since she was born
willow's always been beyond her years
she and
and and jaden both um but i think what
i am most impressed with with willows is
the um courageous young woman
she has become to to you know just be
who she is
and you know and and living her truth
and and that could be a little difficult
for her
age because you know with social media
we didn't have social media right
you know we didn't have to contend with
instagram and all of that
and so it makes it even more challenging
to do you versus what everybody else is
doing
you know what i mean is there a guest
you're dying to have
on the show you know i get asked that
all the time and i have to be honest
with you
i am so grateful for
every single guest
we have ever had on this show
because i understand um
you know the red table is something
that's a little different you know what
i mean
and let me tell you something i have the
utmost respect
utmost love and the deepest appreciation
for every single guest we've ever had
yeah
you know so there's no one person that i
could say oh i would love to
i'm deeply appreciative of anybody who
gives us the opportunity
yeah anybody who wants to sit at that
table exactly
but people want to come to the table now
and that's got to be it's different now
because people are like oh i'm going to
go to the red table y'all
right and now how do you manage that
from where people now are like oh
i'm going to promote my stuff and go to
red tape yeah where you guys really
try to have authentic conversations here
yeah people want to come in like that
yeah they do it's a big thing it's a big
thing and you really have to be ready
i think people think that they want to
come and then when they get here
they see that it's it's not as easy
exactly as you
as you think it's going to be and you
really have to be ready we really have
to know
and feel secure and who you are and what
you're talking about if you're ready
because
a lot of times there's a lot of judgment
that you will be hit with
that you may not be ready for you know
um
and that's not necessarily what what we
want but that is just
how the world is the nature of media and
we're going to do
the nature of human beings we're
judgmental creatures
yeah and we're going to do like we
decided like this year we're going to
start doing some lighter you know what i
mean
right right it's gonna be very heavy
yeah we're gonna start doing some
lighter things
but also keeping our integrity yeah and
keeping the authenticity but you know
there's a way to do that and still have
some fun
yeah by the way where are we right now
so we can tell everybody because the
background is beautiful it looks like an
oasis
this is gammy's island yeah this is
gammy's island island
is right there will calls this her lake
oh really this is your lake no no no
that's gammy's island
and her lake and this is her currently
probably me and jacob your lake yeah
well that's what mr smith says
so you know he's he's the patriarch he's
a patriarchy
that's what mr smith says he says that's
her lake and he says that's her mountain
yeah and he said that's why he wanted to
get this spot
this is his dream like he dreamed of
having his
family on a piece of property he wanted
all his kids
to be able to live here forever because
he you know he grew up watching dallas
he wanted his own dallas you know so
that's what he that's the energy that he
put
into this place that actually has come
to be because the kids are here every
day
even though they're adults and have gone
off and doing their own thing
they're still here every day we all come
here every day
so this is the family compound center
yeah
jaden's ridge you've got willow's peak
um
i think trey's view trey's view um
yeah we have different places that um
for different
family members you also missed do it big
and now you've created another iconic
thing with the red table congratulations
ladies congratulations
it's unbelievable it's been quite a
[Music]
journey